From the start of 2017, the regulations around
small heated pools, such as spa pools and
hot tubs have changed and as long as they
meet the following criteria, they no longer
need to be fenced.
Firstly to fit in this category – the need
to have an area of 5m2 or less and they need
to be designed for therapeutic or recreational
use.
Then it needs to have a suitable cover.
It must restrict the entry of children when
covered.
Able to withstand a reasonably foreseeable
load.
Able to be readily returned to the closed
position.
And have signage indicating its
child safety features.
Every wall of the pool must be higher than
760mm from the ground
and they must be difficult to climb.
The tap or hose that is used to fill the pool,
must be fitted with a backflow preventer.
These inexpensive devices stop water being sucked back into the mains water supply.
Finally you'll need to register your pool
with the council for free.
We’ll come and check that everything is
correct, give you one of these safety stickers
and then you're good to go.